[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Ellen enie
und herzlich willkommen zu diesem
Presseclub am Sonntag schön dass Sie
dabei sind
es ist ein Jahr her das russische
Truppen die Ukraine überfallen haben und
Präsident Putin einen brutalen
Angriffskrieg in Europa angezettelt hat
10.000 sind gestorben Millionen sind aus
der Heimat vertrieben worden und ein
Ende ist nicht in Sicht
die Solidarität mit der Ukraine brachte
zum Jahrestag viele Menschen in
Deutschland auf die Straße aber auch die
Angst vor einer Eskalation des Kriegs
treibt die Menschen um gestern fand in
Berlin die von Sarah Wagenknecht und
Alice Schwarzer initiierte
Großkundgebung statt ihr Manifest für
den Frieden haben mehr als eine halbe
Million Menschen unterschrieben zum
Brandenburger Tor kam laut Behörden rund
13.000 teilnehmende die Demonstranten
verurteilen die westlichen
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine und
fordern stattdessen sofortige
Friedensverhandlungen
ja Frieden wünschen sich alle aber zu
welchen Bedingungen zum Jahrestag des
Kriegs hat China ein Positionspapier
vorgelegt das absichtlich nicht
Friedensplan genannt wird das aber den
Konflikt lösen soll unser Thema heute
chinasvorstoß Chance für den Frieden
oder Blendwerk und ich freue mich auf
diese Gäste die ich alle herzlich
willkommen heiße Dana Heide sie ist
Hauptstadt Korrespondentin des
Handelsplatz vorher China
Korrespondentin Anna no riskevic
Deutschland Reporterin für den US-Sender
CBS Christoph Schilz nato-korrespondent
der Welt in Brüssel und Sebastian
Puschner stellvertretender Chefredakteur
der Wochenzeitung der Freitag und noch
ein Hinweis für Sie liebe Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer sie können sich wie immer
in der Diskussion beteiligen in den
sozialen Medien wo wir diese Sendung
streamen fangen wir vielleicht mit dem
Blick nach Berlin an mehr als 600.000
Menschen haben das Manifest für den
Frieden unterschrieben 13.000 laut
Polizeiangaben waren dort
bewerten Sie diesen Vorstoß Herr
Puschner ich glaube er zeigt auf ein auf
jeden Fall dass es eine große Gruppe von
Menschen gibt in Deutschland die sich
Sorgen machen die nichts dringlicher
wollen als dass dieser Krieg endet so
unterkomplex diese Haltung sein mag
angesichts der komplexen Situation in
der Ukraine und das russischen
angriffskriegs und der folgen aber ich
denke nicht nur die Zahl der
Unterschriften online auch die Zahl der
Protestant der Protestierenden in Berlin
gestern findet sich so findet
Niederschlag in den Umfrageergebnissen
die wir kennen letzte ARD Deutschland
trennt es sind glaube ich knapp 60% der
Menschen die mehr diplomatische
Anstrengung gerne
sehen würden und das glaube ich ist das
allererste was ich artikuliert in dieser
Kundgebung gestern ja sie haben den
Deutschland Trend zitiert das hatte ich
auch vor von daher vielen Dank dafür
Anfang Februar haben tatsächlich 58% der
deutschen gesagt dass ihnen die
diplomatischen Bemühungen zur Beendigung
des Krieges nicht weit genug gegeben
haben Sarah Wagenknecht und alles
schwarzer Weise also mit ihrem Aufruf
doch ein Nerv getroffen was meinen Sie
naja also ich glaube erstmal hat die
Demo gestern gezeigt wie müde die
Menschen wirklich sind und
also dass die Leute auf die Straße gehen
und
überfordert sind auch medial überfordert
sind ist verständlich aber sie haben
also es ging in die in die falsche
Richtung weil letztendlich glaube ich
den Menschen die auf die Straße gegangen
sind nicht wirklich ganz bewusst war
woran Sahra Wagenknecht und Alice
schwarze eigentlich appellieren und zwar
an falschen Frieden der der auf was ganz
falsch übertiert
sie beschreiben es letztendlich sehr
ähnlich wie der Vizekanzler Robert
Habeck der hat bei uns im Brennpunkt am
Freitagabend auch sich sehr sehr klar
geäußert zu dieser Demonstration gestern
wir können mal kurz reinhören
nicht und die ihr folgenden Leute machen
ist nicht ein Frieden zu wollen sondern
ein Frieden den einen Diktator einen
imperialistischer Diktator Europa
aufzwingt als Frieden zu verkaufen und
das wäre nur der neue Outfit in den
nächsten kriegerischen Handlungen wenn
sich das durchsetzt ist das eine
Einladung an Putin die nächsten Länder
zu überfallen an alle irren dieser Welt
die Grenzen mit Waffengewalt zu
verschieben das ist kein Frieden das ist
eine Chimäre die da aufgebaut wird ist
eine politische Irreführung der
Bevölkerung
eine Chimäre eine politische Irreführung
Freiheit sie haben genickt sie sehen das
ähnlich ja sehe ich auch so dass da wird
suggeriert das ist ein Friedenslösung
gibt und die einfach nicht wahrgenommen
wird und Herr Push dass sie sagten das
ist eine große Gruppe die da für den
Frieden man merkt dass das so eine große
Gruppe für den Frieden ist ich glaube
wir sind alle für den Frieden das ist
nicht nur diese Gruppe die da auf die
Straße gegangen sind alle für den
Frieden und das Sprechen diese Leute den
anderen die auch ab die da auf die
Straße gegangen sind und sie tun so als
ob es eine Friedenslösung auf dem Tisch
lege die Verhandlungen könnte man sofort
anfangen und dann gibt's Frieden aber so
ist es eben nicht es ist nicht so aber
man könnte doch jetzt sagen noch mal mit
Blick auf die Demo herrscht also wenn
eine Mehrheit der Deutschen sagt die
diplomatischen Bemühungen reichen nicht
aus und sicherlich viele treibt es um zu
sagen es sterben immer mehr Menschen es
werden immer mehr Waffen geliefert und
der Krieg kommt nicht vom Flex sondern
ist mehr oder weniger festgefroren zu
sagen es muss doch einen anderen Weg
geben können Sie das irgendwo
nachvollziehen
wie sie schon gesagt haben wir wollen
alle Frieden und natürlich ist der beste
Weg die Diplomatie nur dies ist nicht
der Stunde der Diplomatie oder sie wäre
es nur wenn Putin mitmachen würde aber
das ist nicht der Fall und ich sage
deshalb wir müssen mehr Waffen liefern
das hört sich schlimm an ich finde das
selbst auch schlimm aber wir müssen mehr
Waffen liefern wir müssen die Ukraine
besser ausstatten damit Sie in diesem
Krieg stärker auftreten kann und Putin
der ja heute sagen könnte schon ähm ich
höre auf damit aber er tut es eben nicht
und deswegen hat die Diplomatie im
Moment keine Chance
und damit Putin durch mehr Waffen eben
durch massiv mehr Waffen viel stärker
unter Druck geraten würde und dann
möglicherweise Einlenken würde was
Wagenknecht und Co wollen ist ein
Kapitulation Frieden die Ukraine würde
keine Waffenlieferungen mehr bekommen
sollen und würde am Ende aufgeben müssen
das können wir nicht wollen das ist
krude friedenslöhrig was da verbreitet
wurde sie haben jetzt gerade noch mal
gesagt mehr Waffen ich spiele gerne
wieder eine aktuelle
deutschlandtrendzahl ein an der Stelle
Anfang Februar 44 Prozent empfinden die
Unterstützung der Ukraine mit Waffen als
angemessen also eine relative Mehrheit
15 Prozent geht sie nicht weit genug 35%
geht Waffenlieferung zu weit also gut
ein Drittel in Deutschland sagen aktuell
das ist mir schon zu viel Herr pushtner
sie haben es gerade gehört Herr Schild
sagt noch mehr Waffen damit man
überhaupt verhandeln kann
ob es tatsächlich nicht der Stunde ist
weil wenn wir den Diskurs in Deutschland
angucken dann hat sich doch was merklich
verändert erinnern wir uns am Ende des
vergangenen Jahres Anfang dieses Jahres
wir haben vor allem über Waffen wir
haben vor allem über Leopard Panzer
geredet wir reden jetzt in den
vergangenen Wochen doch auch hierzulande
merklich mehr über solche zumindest
Ansätze für Friedensverhandlungen und
ich glaube das hängt zusammen mit
ungefähr dem Zeitpunkt des Besuchs von
Olaf Scholzen Brasilien als auch hier
man nicht mehr darum kam darüber zu
reden was da der brasilianische
Präsident gesagt hat das waren sehr
einfache Wahrheiten unter anderem dass
die halt die Hilfe oder dass die Ukraine
und Russland die Hilfe brauchen von
Staaten dieser Welt um in irgendeiner
Weise ins Gespräch zu kommen und ich
stimme Ihnen völlig zu
Friedensverhandlungen in ihrer wirklich
reinsten Form sind wahnsinnig weit weg
wir haben hier einen Krieg der verharrt
wir spekulieren über offensiven es gibt
die Forderungen nach mehr Waffen die
Frage die ich dann stellen würde wäre ja
wie viele Waffen müssten es denn sein um
tatsächlich zu einer militärischen
Lesung zu kommen ich glaube sehr viel
mehr gesagt wie viele sie braucht sie
kommen nur nicht ja da sind wir aber
dann beim Dilemma des Westens beim
Dilemma Europas vor allem aber auch der
USA ich glaube bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz hat Olaf Scholz
gerade noch mal betont wir werden und
das ist auch die Position des
amerikanischen Präsidenten nicht in der
Ukraine kämpfen und ähm diese dieser
Punkt eben die eskalationsdynamik die
sich mit einer Ausweitung von
Waffenlieferungen verbindet so im Auge
zu haben es erklärte erklärte Politik
sowohl Deutschlands als auch der USA das
heißt
dieses Dilemma aus diesem Dilemma gibt
es kaum ein Entkommen außer der Westen
entschließt sich wirklich massiv in
diesen Krieg zu intervenieren mit allen
Gefahren die damit anhergehen also
meiner Meinung nach sollte man die in
aller Welt sichtbaren Ansätze jetzt aus
China auch aus Brasilien gerade in
Indien beim Besuch von Scholz wurden
auch wieder entsprechende Worte verloren
doch mal ernst nehmen und mal drüber
nachdenken was vielleicht
niedrigschwellige Ansatzpunkte werden
ins Gespräch zu kommen die haben China
gerade noch mal genannt und das ist ja
auch tatsächlich der Titel unserer
Sendung deshalb also jetzt gerne einen
Blick auf das Positionspapier was wir
schon zu Beginn der Sendung eingeführt
haben wurde am Freitag von China
präsentiert übrigens an dem Tag wo auch
noch mal mit überwältigender Mehrheit
eine unresolution verabschiedet wurde
die den Krieg verurteilt Frau Heide als
ehemalige China Korrespondentin sind sie
hier so ein bisschen unsere Expertin was
steht denn genau in diesem
Positionspapier drin also das
Positionspapier
stellt noch mal klar sozusagen stellt
noch mal auf die Position in die China
auch so schon in der Vergangenheit zu
der Ukraine zu dem Ukraine Problem zu
der auch eine Krise wie Sie es nennen
wiederholt quasi diese Positionen noch
mal und die geht eben davon aus und die
stellt sich klar auf die Seite wieder
Russlands berücksichtigt nicht die
Interessen Kiews und sagt im Grunde an
beide jetzt mäßigt euch mal beide und
berücksichtigt in keiner Weise dass
Russland den Krieg angefangen hat dieses
Papier ist keine ehrliche ja stellt
keine ehrliche Unterstützung für einen
Frieden da sondern eine Unterstützung
für einen Frieden nach putins-regeln und
da ist eben die Gefahr dass er kriegt
was er will er kriegt nach einem Jahr
Krieg kriegt er was er will und als
nächstes ist dann ein anderes Land dran
wenn er weiß dass es das ist klappt und
ähm genau nutzt halt diese Initiative um
sich als Friedensstifter darzustellen
man muss alles was China tut vor zwei ja
vor zwei grundannahmestellen einmal die
die Verbindung zu Russland felsenfest
die haben sich vor Kriegsbeginn wenig
kurz vorkriegsbrennen kann sie sich eine
Freundschaft ohne Grenzen geschworen das
heißt die sind felsenfest und sie
bestätigen sich auch immer wieder in
diesem in dieser Freundschaft wangi
fährt zu Putin und diese Bilder sind die
sprechen eine ganz eindeutige Sprache
wir sind Freunde wir stehen an Seite und
das zweite ist China schaut sich alles
vor dem im Hinterkopf weil die haben im
Hinterkopf dass sie einen großen
Konflikt mit den USA haben und das ist
der wichtigere Konflikt und deswegen
brauchen sie Russland sie haben ja jetzt
den großen Rahmen sehr klar gemacht wenn
ich aber noch mal auf das
Positionspapier gucke steht ja ja
zumindest auch drin es wird die
territoriale Integrität der Länder
unterstrichen das kann man jetzt so ein
bisschen in die eine oder in die andere
Richtung lesen also Sie haben gerade
gesagt China stellt sich sehr klar an
die Seite Russlands gleichzeitig steht
da ja aber drin die territoriale
integriert könnte ich könnte ich so
verstehen dass die Ukraine mit ihrer
Ursprungsform gemeint ist ja also ich
denke auch was lässt sehr viel Raum für
für sehr viel Spielraum für
Interpretationen und sie sprechen einmal
von von territorialer Integrität aber
dann im nächsten Satz wird es eigentlich
wieder diskutiert wenn sie sagen oder
wenn das Papier sagt naja aber es gibt
auch legitime Sicherheitsinteressen die
auch gewahrt werden und berücksichtigt
werden werden müssen und das ist ganz
klar dass die Frage wie man es
interpretiert aber es ist ganz klar dass
sich die USA gemeinsam mit China da ganz
Entschuldigung China da gemeinsam mit
Russland ganz klar gegen die USA setzen
und letztendlich ist es also ich
persönlich fand vor allem nach der nach
der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz konnte
man da jetzt nicht so viel erwarten das
war irgendwie überraschend unspekt
spektakulär dieses Positionspapier weil
ja nichts Konkretes vorgeschlagen wurde
also einmal dürfen nicht vergessen dass
China bis heute nicht einmal den Krieg
verurteil sie hat und offen gesagt hat
es ist falsch und ein Waffenstillstand
vorzuschlagen ist bekommen wir
sicherlich gleich noch gleich noch zu
aber ein ganz konkreter irgendwie
Friedensvorschlag wäre zum Beispiel zu
sagen die Truppen müssen abgezogen
werden also einmal die Verurteilung des
Krieges ganz offensichtlich und und
vorzuschlagen dass Russland zurückziehen
sonst ist es das steht nicht drin aber
Herr pushen hat vielleicht äh ich finde
das ist positives ich finde schon es ist
Wert noch auf die weiteren Punkte mal zu
gucken weil es stehen in diesen 12
Punkten auch solche darin die an
bestehende diplomatische
Ansatzpunkte anknüpfen beispielsweise
das Getreide Abkommen ist explizit doch
mal daran erwähnt und es wird daran
erinnert dass es wichtig ist das zu
verlängern das bedient natürlich auch
wie die anderen Punkte in chinesisches
Interesse stand Januar war China das
hauptempfängerland dieser Getreide
Exporte die über dieses Abkommen eben
die helfen verlassen konnten aber es
sind natürlich natürlich auch viele arme
Länder die davon profitieren und an die
richtet sich China ebenso es wird der
Gefangenenaustausch einer der ganz
wenigen Bereiche in diesem russischen
Angriffskrieg wobei das Seiten
miteinander in Verhandlungen
gegengegangen sind und auch hinter den
Kulissen Einigungen erreicht haben
Gefangenenaustausch erreicht haben daran
wird eben noch mal erinnert uns
interessanter Punkt denn natürlich ist
das in chinesisches Positionspapier was
hier in russische Position anlehnt es
wird das Thema Sanktionen auf den auf
den Tisch gelegt und das bedient
einerseits wiederum natürlich ein
eigenes chinesisches Interesse
Handelskrieg mit den USA aber eben auch
teilanfrage naja das stößt natürlich
hier auf absolutes Unverständnis aber
wenn es eines Tages tatsächlich zu einem
Verhandlungsprozess kommen wird dann ist
das natürlich das ist eigentlich ja der
Sinn von Sanktion sie irgendwann auch
wieder zurücknehmen zu können um in
einen Verhandlungsprozess zu gehen ist
für uns heute unvorstellbar aber das
macht diese Position mal klar und legt
das auf den Tischen ich finde da findet
sich schon einiges wo man dran
verknüpften Punkt könnte man sollte
jetzt nicht allzu überrascht davon sein
dass China seine Position und seine
Interessen artikuliert sehen Sie auch
was positives Herr Schilz
eigentlich gar nicht sagen das ist
erstens glaube ich nicht dass China ein
ehrlicher Makler sein kann weil China
hat maßgeblich verhindert dass ich außer
insgesamt 34 Staaten kein anderes Land
im globalen Süden an den Sanktionen
beteiligt und China steht fest an der
Seite Russlands in der Gegnerschaft
gegen die USA die wollen den Machtblock
so wie sie das nennen den amerikanischen
Machtblock brechen und eine Multi polare
Welt so wie Angst sie das jetzt gesagt
hat in München das ist das eine und das
andere ist es wurden
mehrere völkerrechtliche Prinzipien
aufgezählt das hört sich alles gut an
aber das im Prinzipien territorial
Integrität an die sich China gar nicht
hält ja und mich hat ein Punkt mit Blick
auf
Taiwan und die Bett und so weiter und
mich hat ein Punkt vor allem erschreckt
dass dort nämlich in Punkt 2 dieses
zwölf Punkte plant steht dass alle
Partner daran arbeiten sollen eine
balancierte nachhaltige und effektive
europäische Sicherheitsarchitektur
aufzubauen ja was heißt das denn das
bedeutet doch dass die bisherigen
Verträge im Blick auf die europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur die akkordiert
sind nicht taugen dass sie etwas Neues
dass sie eine neue Macht Balance
aufbauen wollen und
das sollte uns aufschrecken lassen ich
glaube dieses Papier ist nichts wert vor
allem auch weil China da bin ich anderer
Meinung als sie nicht in jedem Fall in
Bezug auf die USA wohl aber nicht in
jedem Fall kongruente konkurrente
Interessen mit den mit den großen haben
aber vor allem im Kaukasus und so weiter
und deswegen als ein neuer Spieler der
eigentlich in diesem ganzen Konflikt gar
keine Rolle spielt die Verhandlungen mit
eigenen Interessen noch verkomplizieren
würde also ich erwarte da nichts aber
wir sollten es darf ich kurz noch daran
anknüpfen schon fragen warum der
ukrainische Präsident warum wollte mir
silenski ja darauf reagiert hat indem er
gesagt hat es gibt Punkte in diesen in
diesem Papier die teile ich nicht es
gibt Punkte mit denen kann ich etwas
anfangen und sich jetzt wünscht in einen
vertrauliches Gespräch mit der
chinesischen Führung zu gehen klar das
kann natürlich sein dass der westliche
Druck ist auf ihn sich auch
fahndungsplätze zu geben
ich will nicht reden dann hätten alle
geschrieben und alle gesagt ja der will
ja noch nicht mal und das genau das
würde hätte dann China auch in die Hände
gespielt der will ja noch nicht mal
reden seht ihr die wollen nein Frieden
also natürlich redet er mit aber aber
wenn ich die Argumentation von Herrn
Puschner mal aufgreifen tatsächlich man
kann ja dieses Thema direktoriale
Integrität im Sinne der Ukraine lesen
und ähm es gibt ja auch eine Passage zu
Atomwaffen und atomkriegt der auf gar
keinen Fall stattfinden soll das sind
zwei Passagen die letztendlich der
Ukraine gefallen könnten den
Anführungszeichen ist gerade der zweite
Punkt nicht was was Hoffnung gibt dass
es zu bestimmen
das hätte ich eben antworten sollen das
ist der einzig gut geworden
doch doch das ist der einzig wirklich
vielversprechende Punkt und da haben sie
nämlich auch eine rote Linie gesetzt
gegenüber den Russen ja weil die Russen
wissen jetzt klar wir sollten auch nicht
nur das nicht tun mit der mit der
nuklearnuklearen Atombombe sozusagen
sondern wir sollten auch auf Drohungen
verzichten das ist nicht Interesse der
Chinesen warum ist das übrigens nicht im
Interesse der Chinesen die haben auch
wirtschaftliche Interessen und die sind
der wichtigste importpartner der EU
beispielsweise 22% laut EU-Kommission
des der importierten Waren innerhalb der
EU kommen aus China und eine solche ein
solcher Krieg oder noch schlimmer die
Nuss nukleare Eskalation würde natürlich
das Konsumklima und das
Investitionsklima in der Europäischen
Union und in auch in den USA dämpfen und
damit auch die chinesische Wirtschaft
treffen die die wollen diesen Krieg am
liebsten gar nicht weil er sich stört er
stört ihre Wirtschaftsinteressen aber
sie haben recht das mit der nuklearen
ist ist etwas Gutes weil das ist vor
allem auch in Richtung Russland
gerichtet das war nicht das erste Mal
auch als Scholz in Peking war hat ja der
chinesische Präsident danach das
geäußert und bis heute wird das als
einer der wenigen diplomatischen Erfolge
sozusagen benannt wurde jetzt auch
wieder so benannt zum Beispiel von
Emmanuel macron also
kleinen diplomatischen Ansatzpunkte
nicht immer gleich unter den Tisch
fallen lassen sondern sozusagen
erkannt also ich war bei der Scholz
Reise mit dabei auch habt ihr die
Berichterstattung danach natürlich auch
verfolgt uns auch selber mitgestaltet
aber natürlich wurde das auch anerkannt
und genau es ist würde ich auch sagen
diese nuklear
dieser nuklearpassus das ist wichtig
dass dir das machen dann ist auch
wichtig dass man da immer wieder auch
Druck ausübt aber ich finde sozusagen da
muss man noch mehr man muss China dazu
bringen und ich glaube da wird die
Bundesregierung jetzt auch etwas klarer
zumindest in den Forderungen china hat
Einfluss auf Russland in gewisser Weise
weil Russland immer stärker von China
abhängig wird und diesen Einfluss müssen
sie nutzen und wir brauchen keine nicht
China nicht als friedensvermittler
sondern wir brauchen China dafür dass
China sagt dass China Russland sagt hört
auf damit zieht eure Truppen zurück also
denke ich haben wir ja hier Konsens am
Tisch das China das durchaus aus
Eigeninteresse jetzt unternommen hat
aber man kann ja mal die Absichten neben
ähm hinten runterfallen lassen und sagen
okay aber es ist ein möglicher
gesprächskanal eröffnet wenn überhaupt
hat vielleicht noch die Möglichkeit auf
putinen einzuwirken jetzt hat ja auch
der französische Präsident wurde gerade
schon gesagt am Tisch hier gesagt er
könnte sich vorstellen ab eben april
nach China zu reisen und da weiter den
Kanal voranzutreiben
könnte man jetzt ja sagen okay das ist
ein erster Schritt in die richtige
Richtung es bekommt Bewegung rein alle
haben gesehen dass es so mit dem Krieg
nicht weitergeht und dass er so
verhärtet ist oder also ja die Anleitung
wie man das also ich finde einmal noch
mal um das um das mit dem noch mal zu
den 12 Punkteplan kurz zu kommen
natürlich gibt es da positive Punkte
wenn man sie halt auch so verstehen
möchte wieder die USA noch Russland noch
China haben Interesse an anderen
nuklearen Katastrophe vor allem wenn
oder dann in einer nuklearen
Auseinandersetzung vor allem wenn jetzt
wirklich die drei atomare Weltmächte
irgendwie vielleicht doch zu einem Tisch
kommen oder vielleicht zu einem Konflikt
kommen also da irgendwie positive Dinge
zu sehen und denen auch irgendwie so ein
Vertrauensvorsprung zu geben und dass
sie ja sich als als ähm ja friedvoll und
und ja friedlich irgendwie einsetzen
wollen aber trotzdem wäre ich da so
skeptisch weil wie Frau Heide auch schon
gesagt hat es geht um die eigenen
Interessen von China und letztendlich ob
es nun direkt oder durch Zwischenhändler
halten Sie die die Maschinerie die
kriegt es manchmal Maschinerie in
Russland auch wenn sie sich an teilweise
an irgendwelche Sanktionen gehalten
haben trotzdem halten Sie den die
Maschinerie am am laufen und ich werde
da so vorsichtig jetzt darüber
nachzudenken in irgendwelche
Friedensgespräche mit China einzuführen
wir haben den Fehler die ganze Zeit mit
Russland gemacht die sind immer noch
über einen Überfall auf die Ukraine es
ist ja nicht irgendwie die Chinesen sind
die ganze Zeit Krise oder Problem also
auch ja ähm benennt ja nicht mal nicht
mal beim Namen es ist ein ein Überfall
auf einem souveränen Staat ähm die die
Ukraine muss unterstützt werden wenn wir
noch irgendwelche Werte haben
Deutschland hat aber und die und
Westeuropa hat die ganze Zeit trotz der
ganzen Warnung und ich erinnere noch mal
der Krieg wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit
in den 24 Februar 22 im Kopf aber ich
meine das ist seit 2014 es gab ja immer
wieder irgendwie friedensansätze und und
Franco deutsche des Friedensabkommen
oder die die Waffenstillstands des
Waffen steht das Abkommen in Minsk mit
Holland und Frau Merkel es gab immer
wieder Möglichkeiten beziehungsweise
Bestrebungen irgendwie Frieden in den
Konflikt reinzubringen und jetzt dass da
jetzt China noch irgendwie ein Teil der
Gleichung wird ist beängstigend wir
dürfen diese Fehler nicht noch mal
machen also wir müssen auch sagen wir
haben schon im autokratischen Staat zu
tun der der kein Interesse daran hat
irgendwie an unser Ziel und Tina hat ja
auch keinerlei Erfahrung bei der
Vermittlung von Friedens von Frieden
also sagen die haben das nie gemacht die
können das auch gar nicht so ne also das
ist die haben da keine Erfahrung mit die
haben kein Interesse daran
möchte ich noch sagen wir gehen immer
alle Alarmglocken an bei mir wenn macron
Außenpolitik betreibt ja schauen Sie
sich an was sie in Libyen gemacht hat
gegen die Interessen der EU hat er mit
hafter paktiert schauen Sie sich an was
er in der Sahelzone gemacht hat wo sie
wo die Franzosen abgezogen sind weil sie
dort keiner mehr haben wollte schauen
Sie sich an dass er 2020 noch Putin
hofiert hat und auf seiner
Sommerresidenz empfangen hat macron hat
eigene Interessen und der inszeniert
sich gerne und wenn er klug wäre würde
er andere europäische Führer mitnehmen
und nicht als äh französische solo
Nummer nach Peking fahren sondern andere
Führer mitnehmen Frau von der Leyen die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin vielleicht ein
paar andere kleinere Staaten die dort
legitime Interessen haben wie die beiden
oder die Russen Entschuldigung die
beiden und die Polen oder oder andere
Staaten und das nicht als Solo Nummer
inszenieren
ist kein guter Außenpolitiker ich muss
es so sagen er ist eine eine inkarnierte
Selbstinszenierung und ich fürchte da
wird nichts mehr rauskommen gut jetzt
nehmen wir mal also macron reißt nicht
alleine ich bin ja immer noch dabei es
geht noch soweit ich weiß er will er
will alleine reisen ich bin ja dabei wir
versuchen ja hier zu überlegen welche
Herangehensweisen gibt es denn noch was
kann denn der Westen noch tun also es
ist ja durchaus einsichtig wie sie
gerade argumentiert haben es gibt
Berichte dass China insgeheim Russland
mit Waffen und mit Drohnen versorgen
will das dementiert China aber das
Misstrauen ist ja total berechtigt ne
ich versuche jetzt nur wieder auf den
Punkt zu kommen wenn es denn
möglicherweise ein gesprächskanal gibt
den China besser öffnen kann als andere
und der Westen springt auf und macron
würde nicht alleine reisen sondern würde
Frau von der Leyen und wie noch immer
noch mitnehmen was
kann was muss der Westen jetzt tun ich
verbinde das mit einer Frage von Stefan
Geier können Friedensverhandlungen
erstens ohne eine Rücktrittsforderung an
Putin und sein Regime und zweitens ohne
eine völkerstrafrechtliche Aufarbeitung
von Gutschein mariopol beginnen und hier
auch Joachim VB fragt auf Twitter könnte
China von einem Zerfall der Russischen
Föderation profitieren z.B durch mehr
Einfluss in den sich dann bildenden
Einzelstaaten also ich versuche einfach
mal so ein bisschen die Debatte die
parallel auf Twitter läuft hier mit
reinzubringen aber die große Frage ist
was kann denn wenn das alles so wenig
aussichtsreich ist wie sie gerade
beschreiben was muss der Westen tun ja
bitte ich knüpft vielleicht an den einen
Aspekt den äh der Nutzer aufgebracht hat
an die
justizielle Bearbeitung von
Kriegsverbrechen von Verbrechen gegen
die Menschlichkeit es gibt eine
Institution die dafür zuständig ist das
der Internationale Strafgerichtshof nun
es gibt drei Weltmächte die nicht
anerkennen das ist nicht nur Russland
das ist auch China und das ist die USA
ja das heißt so sehr wir uns das
wünschen unser so sehr gerechtfertigt
dass es ebenso wäre wie
ein die Demokratie und den Frieden
lebender Präsident in der Russischen
Föderation das ist das ist einfach nicht
realistisch das sind nicht
fortbedingungen wir sind nicht in der
Position dass wir die stellen können und
dann das Gespräch gehen ich wollte noch
mal ergänzendes fliegt ja nicht nur
wahrscheinlich eben macron nach Peking
auch Frau Meloni hat sich für dort
wahrscheinlich angekündigt zunächst mal
konnte aber jetzt Alexander Lukaschenko
der russische Machthaber nach Peking ich
glaube vier Tage oder so das heißt die
Kanäle die laufen was aus denen wird
wenn wir sehen aber es gibt auf jeden
Fall Bewegung sie ist erkennbar ob uns
das jetzt passt oder nicht ob die
Verbindungen sozusagen ob die
Vorbedingungen die wir uns wünschen
würden oder nicht ich glaube dass hat
schon damit zu tun das sind weiten
Teilen dieser Welt einfach eine doch
sehr andere Perspektive auf diesen
Konflikt herrscht und eben gerade auch
Olaf Scholz war in Indien viele durch
die Kollateralschäden durch die Folgen
dieses Krieges so schwer getroffen sind
dass sie einfach sich wünschen dass
zumindest die Perspektive an
Verständigung auf zablor rückt ja das
wünschen wir uns auch alle ja die Frage
ist nur wie wir dahin kommen und
ich glaube die Diplomatie das ist nicht
die Stunde der Diplomatie ja ich höre
zwar bei Hintergrundgesprächen in der
NATO dort wird immer häufiger von
Exit gesprochen da wird immer häufiger
von Verhandlungen gesprochen die Fuß
noch nicht mit konkreten Vorstellungen
aber diese Vorstellung wir müssen da
irgendwie rauskommen wie sie auch gesagt
haben die setzt sich durch die Frage ist
nur wie man dann rauskommen kann ja und
solange Putin auf seinen Positionen
behaart wird das schwer werden und ich
fürchte um es mal nach vorne zu schauen
ich fürchte entweder liefert der Westen
massiv mehr Waffen und zwar er tut schon
viel aber tut nicht annähernd genug
damit die Ukraine ihren Anspruch auf
territoriale Integrität umsetzen kann
entweder liefert er mehr Waffen und die
Ukraine wird Tatsachen auf dem
Kriegsfeld schaffen und dadurch eine
stärkere Verhandlungsposition bekommen
und damit möglicherweise auch Putin an
den handlungsverhandlungstisch zwingen
oder die zweite Alternative ist und ich
fürchte darauf wird es hinauslaufen
diese Waffen werden nicht in der
geforderten Menge kommen wie bisher
die Ukraine haben ja präzise gesagt was
Sie brauchen und nur einen kleinen
Bruchteil davon schicken wir bisher und
wenn das nicht der Fall sein wird dann
wird dieser Krieg
ja dann wird dieser Krieg eskalieren und
es wird noch mehr Gebietsverluste der
Ukrainer geben und dann wird dieser
Punkt kommen wo der Westen am Ende sagt
so es reicht uns jetzt und wir müssen an
den Verhandlungstisch zumindest erstmal
einen Waffenstillstand und an den
Verhandlungstisch und dann wird man
natürlich auch eine gesichtswarende
Lösung für Putin versuchen zu bekommen
und die bedeutet dann aber
Gebietsverluste für die Ukraine was im
Moment alle noch ausschließen aber ich
bin ganz sicher dass am Ende dieses
fürchterlichen Krieges leider leider
Gottes Gebietsverluste der Ukraine
stehen werden das wird am Ende Teil der
Verhandlungslösung sein sie haben ja
gerade hergeleitet und gesagt dadurch
dass wir nicht mehr Waffen liefern wird
am Ende der Krieg eskalieren im Sinne
von Russland kann möglicherweise die
Ukraine noch weiter überrennen und noch
größere Teile des Territoriums besetzen
das ist ja jetzt eine eine Logik die sie
entwickelt haben die in der
Politik so nicht unbedingt geteilt wird
sondern da sagt man ja wir gucken genau
was wir liefern können an Waffen um
nicht Kriegspartei zu werden und um den
Konflikt nicht eskalieren zu lassen also
genau die andere Lesart Ukraine nicht
aber warum wird denn aus ihrer Sicht
dann warum werden denn nicht mehr Waffen
geliefert genauso viele wie die Ukraine
sie sich wünscht aktuell
weil der Westen die Angst hat vor einer
Eskalation dieses Konfliktes die Angst
des Westens vor einem überschwappen
dieses Konfliktes auf andere Länder
möglicherweise NATO-Länder oder vor der
nuklear-option diese Angst ist größer
als die Angst vor der Bedrohung der
westlichen Sicherheit durch mögliche
Gebietsgewinne Russlands in der Ukraine
das ist leider so man hat Angst Russland
in die Enge zu treiben und
das Russland dann irgendwann nuklear
vielleicht sogar eskalieren könnte das
ist der frühere deutsche Nato-General
Heinrich Braus nennt das selbst
Abschreckung ja wir schrecken uns selbst
ab man kann auch sagen wir machen uns
vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr in die
Hose weil
wie hoch ist denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass Putin nuklear eskaliert die wird
als sehr gering gesehen da schauen Sie
sich an was der sieprich-chef also von
dem Stockholmer friedensinstitut
kürzlich gesagt hat schauen Sie sich an
was im neuen Bericht des ethnischen
auslandsgeheimdienste steht über die
Sicherheit Estlands in der
internationalen Gemeinschaft die kommen
alle zu dem Schluss die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist zu gering ist
sehr gering weil erstens wäre der
militärische Erfolg dadurch äußerst
bescheiden also ich rede von einer
taktischen von taktischer
Nuklearwaffen das heißt äußerst
begrenzte wo vielleicht ein Wald oder
ein See oder ein Dorf angegriffen wird
nicht die große Option ja also der
militärische Erfolg wäre äußerst
begrenzt und was viel mehr noch wirkt
und Putin abschrecken sollte ist dass
die USA dann
auf konventionelle Weise massiv
zurückschlagen werden und zwar die die
russischen Kräfte in der Ukraine
angreifen werden und in diesem Fall wenn
ich das noch letzter Satz in diesem Fall
stünde Putin vor der Frage will ich mich
wirklich in einen Krieg mit der NATO
begeben deswegen er nutzt diese nukleare
Karte um uns immer aufzustecken aber er
wird sie nicht sehen also sie haben sehr
klar gemacht aus ihrer Sicht müssen mehr
Waffen und schnelle Waffen geliefert
werden ist das Konsens am Tisch
hier hier wird gewickt
würde mal vorschlagen wir verfolgen
weiter die diplomatischen Initiativen
auch wenn ich da hier in der
Minderheiten Position bin aber es sind
ja jetzt Waffenlieferungen beschlossen
worden und wir können uns jetzt hier
deren Ausweitung wünschen aber was sie
gerade beschrieben haben ist er im
Grunde genommen dass Dilemma der
westlichen Ukraine Politik schon seit
sehr viel längerer Zeit als 2022 nämlich
Versprechungen zu machen und Dinge in
Aussicht zu stellen aber den Preis den
das kostet dafür nicht zu bezahlen weil
dann müsste man eben tatsächlich das
austesten was sie sagen geht er wirklich
so weit ich meine die russische nuklear
Doktrin ist ziemlich klar wenn sozusagen
das eigene Land in irgendeiner Weise
bedroht ist dann ähm ist der Griff zu
den Atomwaffen sozusagen der der
Automatismus oder angeraten ich glaube
es gibt gute Gründe dass weder der
US-Präsident noch der deutsche
Bundeskanzler oder so weiter so weit
gehen wollen und das ist wie gesagt das
Dilemma dass die deutsche und natürlich
die amerikanische
Politik gegenüber der ukrainischen seit
sehr sehr langer Zeit prägt ich würde
gerne eine Sache noch ergänzen auch
wieder mit Bezug auf China aber sehr
schön gesagt hat wie groß ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Protein
Nuklearwaffen einsetzt da hat natürlich
schon auch China einen Anteil dass es
noch mal eine Hürde ist für Putin zu
sagen weil China ist der einzige
mächtige wirklich mächtige Freund noch
den den russland hat und den zu
verlieren und auf Dauer zu verlieren
dass es natürlich wird natürlich Ihnen
auch beschäftigen sozusagen und davon
auch eher abhalten diesen nuklear-schlag
zu machen und ja Entschuldigung also ich
glaube auch die Essenz hier in den
Beziehungen ist das alle das einfach die
die atomare Katastrophe als Abschreckung
als Abschreckung bei allen wird es wird
bei in den USA in China und Russland was
ich vor ein paar Minuten schon sagen
wollte ähm wir dürfen auch nicht
vergessen dass die Ukraine immer noch
ein Selbstbestimmungsrecht hat und wir
sollten beraten zur Seite stehen und
unterstützen zur Seite stehen aber die
ganzen diplomatischen Bestrebungen und
Besuche in Peking ist es jetzt glaube
ich irgendwie zwei Schritte vor dem
ersten in erster Linie ist es so dass
wir auch anerkennen müssen dass die
Ukraine immer noch entscheidet wie viel
Sie bereit sind zu verlieren welche
Opfer sie bereit sind zu geben wir
wissen dass dass die ukrainische
Regierung die die die die Halbinsel Krim
zurückerobern möchte oder zurück haben
möchte genauso wie dann jetzt und ähm
sie prognostizieren dass das dann bei
den Verhandlungen wahrscheinlich darauf
dazu kommen wird dass sie das abtreten
müssen glaube ich persönlich nicht also
ähm wenn die Ukraine die Unterstützung
bekommt die sie braucht und ich glaube
jetzt mit China am Tisch und mit China
dass wir überhaupt uns treffen und über
China sprechen signalisiert den
Amerikanern und zwar über parteilich
also nicht in der Demokraten sondern
auch den Republikanern das dass die das
die Ukraine unterstützt werden muss mit
allen Mitteln deswegen glaube ich dass
wir in den nächsten paar Wochen uns auf
jeden Fall über die Lieferung von
Kampfjets unterhalten werden auch wenn
die Bundesregierung gesagt halt stopp
bei Leoparden machen wir Schluss aber
auch die Stimmen an an den also an den
zeitlines der der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz war ganz klar dass
die nächste dass der nächste also sogar
republikanische Stimmen wo er ganz viele
sagen oh Gott aber da wird sie auch noch
mal irgendwie bei den Amerikanern
Konflikte geben inwiefern auch die
Republikaner unterstützen werden aber
ich brunostiziere das ähm dass wir den
nächsten Wochen ganz klar auch über die
Lieferung von Kampfjet sprechen werden
in den USA also von den USA aber auch
von von Westeuropa sie haben aber sehr
richtig festgestellt dass tatsächlich
also dieses die Ukraine kriegt alles was
sie braucht und das wurde ja schon
mehrfach gesagt sowohl von US-Präsident
beiden aber auch alles was Sie brauchen
soll alles bekommen was sie braucht das
sagt auch Olaf Scholz das sagt auch
Annalena baerbock das sagt auch Robert
Habeck aber sie sagen das kommt nicht
genug und nicht schnell und überhaupt
und vor allem steckt dahinter ja die
Frage für das was die Ukraine braucht um
die Krim zurückzuerobern also der Status
quo ante 2014 oder das was sie braucht
um zumindest in den Tag vor dem Krieg
zurückzukommen also der 23 Februar 2022
selensky hat ja ganz klar gesagt die
Rückeroberung des ganzen Territoriums
der der Ukraine also auch der Krim
glauben Sie dass der Westen wirklich
also Sie haben es gerade ausgeführt die
USA werden so lange unterstützen glauben
Sie wirklich dass die die Einheit des
Westens so lange halten wird das eine
rückerrung der Krimi erreicht werden
kann ich kann dazu sagen ich habe diese
Frage habe ich im Rahmen des letzten
NATO Verteidigungsminister Treffen im
Hintergrund ein Minister gestellt haben
Sie eigentlich Interesse daran dass die
Krim wieder zurückerobert wird so wie
silence geht das möchte und hat dieser
Minister zu mir gesagt ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß es nicht und das hat mich ein
wenig verwundert weil es mir klar macht
dass der Westen wie schon in Afghanistan
gar keine einheitliche Definition dessen
hat was wollen wir hier über und was
wollen wir überhaupt erreichen ja wie
weit wollen wir die Krim unterstützen
die Ukraine unterstützen wollen wir
wirklich wollen wir wirklich das mit
westlichen Waffen die Ukraine in einer
blutigen Schlacht zurückerobert wird ich
habe den Eindruck aus meinen Gesprächen
nein das wollen sie nicht aber anstatt
darüber zu diskutieren bei all diesen
vielen Konferenzen hat jeder so seine
eigene Vorstellung übrigens auch mit dem
zukünftigen Umgang mit Russland ja die
einen wollen das Russland völlig am
Boden liegt die anderen wollen möglichst
bald wieder nach einem Waffenstillstand
ins Gespräch kommen ist ja eine wichtige
macht aber ich glaube das selenskys
Interessen nicht unbedingt die
Interessen im vollen Umfang des Westens
sind oder Teile des Westens und wir
vergessen wie gefährlich
Waffenstillstände sein können also ich
ist wirklich also da muss man ein
bisschen so vorsichtig sein weil wir das
ja auch aus der Geschichte kennen wenn
man irgendwie Waffen im Vagus in
Jugoslawien also sehr bis heute sagen
wir okay das
hätte verhindert werden können wenn wir
das jugoslawienweite Waffen im Wald und
nicht ausgerufen hätten dann bestes
Beispiel
2015 nach Münster nach dem Minsk
Abkommen dass ich vorher erwähnt hatte
ich glaube drei Tage später war eine
blutige Schlacht um oder blutige Sturm
auf auf ähm
den Wald zu warten in der Ukraine und
der Anfang der der das Konflikt in der
vor allem wenn er auch so keine war von
paramilitärischen Organisation von
Proxies von Kriminellen von ähm einfach
pro russischen Truppen die zu allen
Mitteln greifen werden wenn wir einen
einen jetzt frühzeitig an
Waffenstillstand ausrufen ich glaube ich
glaube was da auch sehr wichtig ist
China schaute also sozusagen wir sind
jetzt in diesem Konflikt aber es gibt
noch ein viel größeren Konflikt der uns
erwartet in den nächsten Jahren und das
ist der Konflikt und Taiwan und China
schaut sehr genau hin sehr genau hin was
was der Westen jetzt macht wie vereinte
Westen ist in seiner Reaktion auf die
Ukraine ist glaube ich ein guter eine
sehr gute Reaktion gewesen china hat
gesehen der Westen ist geeint wir haben
sofort reagiert wir haben gemeinsam
reagiert und hören jetzt auch nicht auf
zu reagieren weil es ist immer noch eine
Reaktion auf den Angriff es ist keine es
ist keine Offensive und deswegen ist das
so essentiell dass man da zusammen steht
und zeigt so nicht wir akzeptieren ist
nicht dass ein anderes Land in einem
anderen Land einfällt und das für sich
verändern wir sind schon fast am Ende
der Sendung ankommen ich möchte gerne
noch eine Frage an den pushen erstellen
nämlich unter anderem auch auf Twitter
wird gefragt welche wirksam Druckmittel
außerhalb der militärischen Stärken der
Ukraine gibt es denn um Putin vielleicht
zu Verhandlungen zu bewegen ja ich
glaube das würde ja heute auch schon
mehrmals betont china ist ein ganz
wichtiger Akteur denn Russland ist in
vielerlei Hinsicht von China abhängig
und wie China sich positioniert dass und
sich weiter verhält das wird es die
russische
Position sicherlich nicht unbeeinflusst
lassen ich möchte immer noch vielleicht
einmal abschließend in Erinnerung rufen
ja Waffenstillstände mögen gefährlich
sein können aber erinnern wir uns doch
daran dass was ist denn vor allem auch
gefährlich gefährliches Krieg es sterben
jeden Tag Tausende von Menschen im
Moment also ist ja nicht so dass wir mit
einem Waffenstillstand jetzt in eine
Situation gehen würden die in
irgendeiner Weise
sag ich mal gefährlich ist
unterbrechen wir könnten hier noch sehr
sehr lange weiter diskutieren engagiert
das war der Presseclub im ersten für
heute es geht weiter mit dem
europamagazin wenn sie aber Presseclub
nachgefragt hören wollen und diese
engagierte Diskussion weiterverfolgen
wollen können Sie das auch Phoenix auf
WDR 5 und den sozialen Medien tun vielen
Dank bis hierhin noch einen schönen
Sonntag
[Musik]
und da sind wir wieder mit Presseclub
nachgefragt auf Phoenix WDR 5 und in
Social Media Chinas Vorstoß Chance für
den Frieden oder Blendwerk Fragezeichen
haben wir hier schon eine
Dreiviertelstunde gut diskutiert und
jetzt sollen aber ein Hörerinnen und
Hörer Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer zu
Wort kommen und ich möchte gerne zu
Herbert Koch nach Biebertal schalten
guten Morgen guten Mittag ja guten Tag
meine Frage ist
die die Frieden haben wollen ohne Waffen
die werden oft nicht so nachgefragt dass
sie mal erklären sollen wie das
geschehen kann man hört nicht oder auch
Tina und sie
wieder
ich habe dann entsteht kann der Eindruck
entstehen
sie wissen wie es geht die anderen
wollen nicht aber es wird nicht
nachgefragt was sie wie sie als
einschätzen das wie das praktisch
geschehen soll das möchte ich einfach so
in die Runde geben wie soll man zu einem
Frieden in der Ukraine kommen wenn die
Waffenlieferungen jetzt gestoppt werden
ist ihre Frage wer
das ich kann da gern drauf antworten
weil das weil ich da selbst mit mir
wahnsinnig Ringe und ich glaube man wird
mit einer Antwort
dahingehend man kommt dahin gehen so
eine Antwort dass man sagt dass es sich
sowohl Sarah Wagenknecht als auch die
besonders lauten Befürworter davon
Waffenlieferungen beide sehr einfach
machen denn natürlich ist die
Unterstützung wäre ohne die
Unterstützung vor allem der USA
der Ukraine der gegen den russischen
Angriff die Ukraine ganz schnell
überrannt und eingenommen worden
natürlich werden damit auch noch viel
grausame Art und Weise in ternationale
Standards das Völkerrechts verletzt
worden also beide Seiten aber
gleichzeitig wohnt eine Ausweitung der
Waffenlieferung immer auch eine
eskalationsgefahr eine ich glaube man
wird am besten finde ich bei bei Jürgen
habermaß und seinem letzten say in der
Süddeutschen Zeitung wo er sagt dass es
gerechtfertigt ist die Ukraine mit
Waffen zu unterstützen dass daraus aber
wiederum auch eine Verantwortung
erwächst sich für ein Ende dieses
Krieges und damit schließlich über
Diplomatie und ähm Verhandlungslösung
einzusetzen
danke für die Antwort wir gehen weiter
zu Rainer gorning nach Hamburg hallo und
fragen Sie bitte die Runde
ja im Prinzip angelehnt an meinem
Vorredner
glaube ich wäre es auch mal interessant
zu erfragen wie welche Vorstellung
lieferungsbefürworte also derer die
schwere Sachen befürworten welche
Vorstellungen sie für einen
Friedensschluss haben denn ich sag mal
die Politik steht ja wirklich im
Spannungsfeld zwischen einer
eskalationsgefahr auf der einen Seite
und natürlich den Wunsch die Ukraine und
reingehen dass sie ja nicht weggehen ich
habe bisher und das muss man einfach mal
so sagen auch noch nicht keine konkreten
Schritte Bezug auf einen friedensfluss
von den Waffenlieferung stehen lassen
lieferungsgeführt worden angehört und
das wäre glaube ich online interessant
zu erfragen
zwischenzeitlich nicht ganz gut
verstehen aber den Grundgedanken haben
wir glaube ich alle mitbekommen und ich
würde diese Frage einfach mal an Herrn
ja danke ja gar nicht
wir wollen alle Frieden wie gesagt nur
immer davon zu reden und von Waffen
Waffenstillstandsverhandlungen und einer
Verhandlungslösung ist das eine wenn
Putin da nicht mitmacht
Putin macht einfach nicht mit und wir
müssen sehen dass Putin die Wurzel allen
Übels ist nicht irgendjemand anders
nicht die Amerikaner nicht die Chinesen
und vor allem nicht die Ukraine es ist
einzig und alleine Putin und um
zu einem zu einer Lösung zu kommen am
Ende muss ich leider sagen ich pointiere
es jetzt etwas über es ist Frieden
schaffen mit Waffen das ist es wir
müssen Putin so weit bringen dass er
bereit ist zu verhandeln
ich sehe keine andere Möglichkeit alles
andere ist ein Wunschkonzert das ist
legitim ich würde mir auch anders
wünschen aber das ist ein brutaler
Aggressor
und
[Musik]
wenn er jetzt weitere Erfolge hat in der
Ukraine weitere Land Gewinne wird es für
die Ukraine immer schwerer werden weil
du brauchst ja viel mehr Kraft
Gebiete zurück zu erobern als sie zu
verteidigen und es wird immer schwerer
werden und es wird immer schwieriger
werden in den Verhandlungstisch zu
bekommen deswegen wäre es aus meiner
Sicht wichtig
verstärkt Waffen zu liefern damit dann
möglichst schnell daran haben wir alle
Interesse möglichst schnell einen
Waffenstillstand erreicht werden kann
danke wir hatten also einmal die Frage
Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen Frieden
schaffen mitwaffen ich würde jetzt gerne
weitergehen zu bolco Lewin von Katte
nach Meerbusch hallo und ihre Frage für
diese Runde bitte
gern herzlichen Gruß in die Runde
mir geht es ein bisschen zu wenig um
China selbst und daher meine Frage ist
das was deine Ukraine stattfindet nicht
eigentlich eine Blaupause für die
chinesische Politik wie sie es mit
Taiwan anstellt und deswegen hält sich
China auch zurück und guckt welche
Option zur Verfügung stehen dass dann zu
machen und was die
Unabhängigkeit der Staaten betrifft da
bezieht natürlich China Teil war nicht
als eigenen Staat an sondern als Teil
des eigenen Landes
ja danke für Ihre Frage Frau Heide sie
hatten das Thema ja schon mal kurz
angerissen ja sehr gern also kluge
Beobachtung dass Teile ich auch also das
ist eine der ukraine-krieg ist und die
unsere Reaktion darauf ist ja so wichtig
weil es eben genau China schaut sich das
im Blick auf Taiwan sehr genau an
China bereitet auch mit allem was Sie
jetzt tun an Friedensinitiativen es gab
diese glaube Security Initiative diese
Woche bereitet vor dass es okay ist dass
man in ein anderes Land einfällt und mit
allen Verbündeten z.B auch mit Russland
bringt China das
Commitment ab dass das Taiwan ein Teil
ein territoritaler Teil von China ist
und deswegen ist auch okay ist wenn sie
sich das komplett einverleiben das heißt
ja das ist auch eine Blaupause für das
ähm was was möglicherweise teilhabung
steht und Tina schaut auch sehr genau
hin wie militärisch wie militärisch
reagiert wird um daraus zu lernen für
einen möglichen Angriff auf
Taiwan für sich selber ja
danke wir gehen weiter zu Jürgen Fuchs
nach edersleben guten Tag und was
möchten Sie von der Runde wissen ja
guten Tag an die Hunde ich habe eine
einen die Dame rechts von ihnen von
meinen CBS
zu den Diskussionen um diese
friedensveranstaltungen die jüngst waren
deutete ist sehr Ansprache an das dies
was dort vertreten wird falscher Frieden
ist
ich
ein richtiger Frieden
jeder wird ist doch ein Frieden im Sinne
des Erhalts von leben ihre narrative
kann ich nicht verstehen
nur noch eine Randbemerkung vieles geht
es noch zu dem Herrn
nato-vertreter zu sagen seine narratives
sind mir sehr sehr beste
von der Welt so ja meine Frage geht die
Dame von ihnen rechts was ist ein
falscher Frieden guten Tag Herr Fuchs
vielen Dank für die Frage also wenn
jetzt die Ukraine in die Knie gezwungen
wird und ihr Territorium komplett abgibt
und kapituliert und sagt dann jetzt die
Krim gehören Russland wir sind neutral
es gibt keine Natur Beitrags
Bestrebungen und keine eu-beitrag
geschrieben und dann gibt's
wahrscheinlich für für Putin Frieden und
dann wird er genau das gleiche versuchen
in anderen Ländern wie z.B mal da werden
oder in den bayerischen Staaten Frieden
wäre dann auch für China wenn ich China
Taiwan erobert und das Teil des
Territorium macht also das ist falscher
Frieden jetzt zu sagen wir liefern keine
Waffen mehr wir unterstützen die
Ukrainer nicht mehr in diesem
Angriffskrieg in diesem überfallskrieg
auf auf die Nationen wer fatal und und
da würden sehr viele Menschen daran
sterben und deswegen es ist absolut
falsch zu sagen wir gehen jetzt zum
Verhandlungstisch und es ist quasi eine
Kapitulation
danke und wir gehen weiter zu Marke
Pirschel nach Karben in der Nähe von
Frankfurt am Main hallo schön dass Sie
mit einer Frage dabei sind ja schönen
guten Tag in die Runde ich war gestern
auch live dabei bei der Demo in Berlin
und das hat mir so ein bisschen
irgendwie irritiert die Äußerung von der
Dame von CBS ich habe sie so
wahrgenommen dass sie irgendwie was
Falsches gemacht haben und meine
konkrete Frage wäre
was ist denn das Ziel oder was sollte
das Ziel der deutschen Bemühungen sein
mein Ziel was ich sehe ist das Töten zu
beenden ich vermute es gibt andere Ziele
Russland zu bestrafen oder das
Territorium zurück zu bekommen für die
Ukraine aber was steht denn für sie an
erster Stelle das finde ich mal
interessieren
vielen Dank also das Töten zu beenden
ist ist absolut Priorität Nummer eins
aber das erreichen wir halt nicht wenn
wir aufhör so keine Verteidigungswaffen
zu schicken also
wir müssen weiter die Ukraine mit allen
Mitteln
unterstützen damit der Krieg nicht immer
blutiger wird und das ist natürlich auch
ja sollte auch Deutschlands Ziel sein
und es ist auch Deutschlands das Ziel
von Deutschland die Frage ist nur wie
mein Kollege hier auch gesagt hat
heißt mehr Waffenlieferungen dass es zu
mehr Eskalation führt und das ist immer
eine Abwägungsfrage aber das Ziel ist
natürlich Menschenleben zu retten aber
das schaffen wir nur indem wir die
Ukraine jetzt in diesem Krieg
unterstützen
danke und wir gehen wieder in den Norden
zu Klaus Borchert aus Börsen bei Hamburg
als in Schleswig-Holstein Herr Borchert
Ihre Frage bitte ja moin moin moin moin
ja Frage Hoffnung würde hier sagen also
ich habe die Hoffnung dass alles was er
jetzt passiert letzten Endes dazu führt
dass Herr Putin im eigenen Land nicht
mehr akzeptiert wird weil auch wenn er
den Krieg gewinnen sollte gegen die
Ukraine was hat Russland denn damit
gewonnen steigt dadurch der
Lebensstandard der Menschen im Land das
ist doch alles das ist doch alles nur
einer
selbstverständigen das bringt doch
nichts für die russische Bevölkerung
wir haben das nur Nachteile und und ihre
Ihre Frage an die Runde ja
vielleicht auch
die Dame Chancen
den an seiner eigenen Politik scheitert
und quasi Termin oder irgendwas
ähnlichen entmachtet wird okay die Frage
wie geht es in Russland weiter ist Putin
Teil des Problems ist es ohne ihn
leichter oder schwieriger ich
sie dürfen gerne noch mal von euch
vielen Dank ich klar ich denke natürlich
ist es für alle Beteiligten nicht nur in
diesem Konflikt sondern in vielen
Konflikten einfacher wenn das jetzige
die jetzige russische Regierung
inklusive putinen ähm abdankt und sich
zurückzieht so einfach ist es halt nicht
weil ähm Putin und seine Regierung noch
weitere Bestrebungen haben jedenfalls
nur so können wir es deuten also ich
glaube Russland würde es auch besser
gehen wenn sie jetzt nicht Kriege führen
führen würden wie zum Beispiel den
jetzigen der Ukraine
darf auch noch was ja moin Herr Borchert
wenn ich noch was dazu sagen dürfte in
der Rede vor wenigen Tagen die Putin
gehalten hat hat er noch mal klar
gemacht dass für Russland dieser Krieg
ein Überlebenskampf ist und das ist die
Antwort auf Ihre Frage das narrativ von
Putin ist wir kämpfen um unsere
überleben wir kämpfen gegen den Westen
dies ist kein Kampf gegen die Ukraine
dies ist ein Kampf gegen den Westen es
ist ganz essentiell was wir hier tun und
das soll auch das russische Volk davon
haben sie sollen überleben und das ist
das narrativ das er verbreitet
das ist natürlich Unsinn aber für ihn
ist sehr wichtig dass die Unterstützung
des Volkes bleibt wir hoffen alle dass
das nicht so ist aber im Moment sieht es
nicht so aus dass ich das ändern könnte
leider Gottes auch nicht in den
Oligarchen Eliten aber das kann ja noch
werden
wir danke bis hierhin wir versuchen noch
eine Frage unterzubringen dann sind wir
nämlich auch am Ende der Sendung
angekommen Werner Trost aus Regensburg
Ihre Frage bitte
guten Tag
Bemühung ist kostbar auch die Chinas
allerdings muss man wissen ob der
Anbieter dieser Lösungen seriöse ist die
Seriosität dieser Lösung ist für mich
ein Punkt der sich darum entscheidet ob
nun China die territoriale Integrität
meint mit oder ohne die annektierten
Gebiete wenn das mit diesem Gebieten
gemeint ist dann kann man das alles
verwerfen können Sie mal sagen wie das
gemeint ist wir wollen zumindest gerne
interpretieren wie es gemeint sein
könnte Frau Heide ja es ist sehr sehr
gute Frage weil sich da China auch unter
widerspricht widerspricht sich selber
deswegen ist es sehr schwierig auch zu
deuten was sie genau meinen Mann kann
sie nicht direkt fragen weil sie da auch
dann wieder ausweichend Antworten das
ist eine Interpretationssache die sagen
und und sozusagen das ist auch wieder
das ist das große Ganze auf das große
Ganze zu gucken china hat andere
Vorstellungen von territorialer
Integrität als wir sie so kennen ähm da
entscheiden eben auch Länder wie
Russland darüber ob etwas ein Land
verdient hat territorial integer zu sein
oder ob
die Sicherheitsbedürfnisse eines anderen
Landes in diesem Fall Russland über dem
stehen und das findet sich in der
Friedensinitiative wieder es findet sich
in der global security Initiative wieder
es findet sich in vielen also sozusagen
in der
Großmächte entscheiden darüber ob ein ob
die Sicherheitsinteressen eines Landes
überwiegen und ist okay ist auch in ein
anderes Land einzufallen und das
legitimiert dann wiederum auch so ein
Angriff auf Ukraine und am Ende
entscheidet es die Interpretation von
China danke für diese geopolitische
Einlassung am Ende dieser Sendung jetzt
sind wir tatsächlich auch mit dem
nachgefragt fertig danke für Ihr
Interesse ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen
schönen Sonntag machen sie es gut
tschüss
[Musik]